Right, so in this video, I'm going to give you a couple of tips about ABC strategy or
I could say, you know, the things that you should avoid in ABC strategy.
So the very first thing that I have seen people do is making this big mistake, right?
So let's assume that you have an A leg, you have the B leg, and then you have the C leg.
So a lot of people consider this as a C leg.
For me, this is not a C leg because look at this, right?
Price has went way far above.
So this for me is a breakout, right?
It has to go to a certain degree.
It should not just keep on going up and then you expect the price to come back below and
break this.
This makes no sense, right?
You usually want to look for price to go fake out above the high, right, which is here.
And it should not go like this with volume, it should just not keep on going up.
No, you have to train your eyes to see valid ABCs.
So this could be a valid ABC at this distance, right?
You know, let's see, let me see.
So around 30 pips on GPPUSD is a valid fake out, right?
Or even 35, okay?
But more than that, it becomes risky, okay?
So make sure you avoid that because I have seen a lot of people making this mistake in
the Discord server.
They just keep on looking for that same level.
When price goes up like that, you want to wait for price to give you another ABC.
Look for another ABC rather than waiting for this level to be, you know, hit because
let's assume that price comes back and breaks some structure, right, around here.
So you have your entry here now.
Now if we look at the auto flow trading strategy, what reason the price has to just not, you
know, mitigate an auto block over here and just create another higher high, right?
So this makes sense.
It can just, you know, come into this OB and it just peers through your level because
this is not, this right here is not a fake out.
It's simply a breakout, right?
So yeah, you want to keep that thing in mind.
Secondly, if you want to improve your ABC setups, there's this thing called.
So actually, ABC is range trading.
And what I mean by range trading is that it's not, it's not that you have to only trade
ABCs in the ranging market, but the whole setup, this ABC setup, right, is a range, right?
So you have a range high and then you have a range low.
So price has to take a bar side to take out the sell side and vice versa.
So to actually increase the wind rate of this, what you can look for is when you have
an A leg and then you have the B leg, right?
You want to see some rejections around the A leg high, you know, to build, it's going
to build up some liquidity, right?
And then you look for a C leg and then you wait for change of collector market to shift
and you take your entry and target this level, oops, my bad.
Oh my God, dude, um, I messed up, so let me draw this out again.
You have, you know, the B leg and then you have some liquidity build up around the A level
high and then you have the C leg, you take your entry, boom, boom.
So what happened here is that when you have an A leg here, right?
This is the high of the A leg and we have this B leg.
So before price creates a C leg, you know, price this consolidates near this A leg high.
So it can give a small push.
It could be a small push like this, right?
It doesn't have to be big.
Could be just be some sort of consolidation happening around here because usually when
you only trading like ABCs like this, you know, this, this, this, you know, shows me
there's volume to the upside because price is just going to pierce through above this
level and not come back and take out this level.
So you have, there is a less chance, there's, um, you know, um, there's a 40% chance that
it's going to play out, uh, but there's a 60% chance that it won't play out.
Why?
Because, you know, you have no consolidation after the B leg formation near the A leg high.
So a prime setup for me would be, you know, I want to see some sort of consolidation around
this level before price takes out the A level high, you know, and it can just take
out the A leg, A leg high, come back, do a market structure shift, take your entry and
boom.
So I hope this, uh, video, uh, gives you some sort of information and make sure you, um,
practice this, uh, you know, and just, just get used to this, uh, uh, pattern, right?
Uh, I want to see some sort of consolidation around the A leg high, or if you are looking
for a long position, you want to see some sort of consolidation around, you know, this
level, which would be this and boom, this would be it.
So let's move on to the next video.